it's it's it's really hard for me also
to imagine how someone beats hikaru in
one of these matches since it's been
years since he's lost one i think the
last time he lost an scc match was uh
probably before you were streaming um i
think that's that's right about when uh
you know the the treaty of appomattox
was signed yeah yeah the fall of the
ottoman empire happened a couple days
before hikira lost his last match you're
never going to beat hikaru his own game
not in these positions i mean he's just
going to steamroll
ow
gf and e7 queen takes g6 it's over
bishop c1 is a nice move too
oh yeah bishop c1 would be nice there it
is there it is
a little late but better late than never
ooh
apparently that was a mistake but
queen f7 oh who knows wait that's one oh
my god it's going to get mated on h3
there's made almost queens oh my
goodness he missed me
he's gonna flag
what
oh my goodness unbelievable huge howler
by hikaru forgetting about the h3 pawn
players
three results are possible here by the
way like white could mess this up
yeah like if you go rookie one maybe
black gets knight d2 and then yep pawn
home okay well ding has to make a
decision here
he's down and there it is e5
d7 rookie bishop c6 i guess
and i still think
it takes but the bishop is going to move
away from c6 and white's going to give
up the rook for the b pun and push the c
pawn
yeah now ding is completely winning here
bishop a4
this is easy
c6 and c7 big c7 huh and ding's going to
win this game
oh my goodness very impressive
very impressive
oh that was the idea queen e5 bishop f4
oh my goodness i think ding's going to
lose one second left
now white is winning
apparently
oh e4
i think he fours the move
hey car was like calculated but he's
gonna win
wow
unbelievable turn i mean this is what
kills you in a match with the car with
these games
they destroy your morale
and they destroy your match score yeah
i mean
then you can ask the player like did you
lose the match because this move like
hurt your morale and they're like no i
lost because then it gave my opponent
points and they were ahead of me
and this and the smarter chess odds
predictions right above the players
heads
that you all can see right now are
suddenly i mean that's how close the
match is that this one game has got
these two bars sort of like just
suddenly
coming straight close to 50 50 from a
match which was generally favored almost
75 25 for hikaru before the match
started that one crushing win with black
and
yeah
and nikaru shaking his head here is the
queen almost trapped
um by knight b5
both rooks attacked
it's a position where it's hard not to
resign even
and
that's what he chooses to do he plays a
move and then just resigns before uh
before ding can can eat up all the rooks
yeah ding with a few too many mistakes
this game
oh yeah and i see why my knight a4 move
doesn't work white just plays bishop f2
and
after queen's trade the rook on e8's
hanging so we can't get the c pawn
yep digging down to 10 seconds he does
take on c3 and i think we are precisely
going to see bishop f2
an end game and a breakthrough with b5
is going to win hikaru the game
yeah
i mean even after knight d3 could play
b5 you could you could pre-move b5
ding might try 97 knight b8
yeah
oh playing bishop that goes for bishop
to a7 oh the point is b5 yeah knight b a
bishop a7 very very
precise
yeah
not giving any additional chances and a
big big win for nakamura here
that was a nice one
just what he needed
just what he needed there
knight c4 yeah hikaru is playing this
perfectly by the way wow he has not
given ding a single chance
and here comes the knight back from d3 i
think he's going around to e5
wow this bullet game has already taken
four minutes off the clock
oh why
yeah why that'll still be just one piece
wait a second 96 the car was giving up
the g pawn why did he why did he go to
b7 with his king that was this very
surprising decision now ding is winning
again
i think the car just forgot about the
jeep on i'll believe it when he wins the
end game albert exactly
there goes another pawn he's up two pawn
this is a lot likely winning oh it looks
you could just super super immediately
oh i don't like g6 well he left black
blockade him
[Laughter]
he should throw in knight g4 maybe it's
oh he just walks his king around where
is he going
how is he gonna get there
i don't know i can't keep track of it
it's too many nights in progress that a
car is still not giving up
oh didn't give up a pawn but okay knight
two four nine f six
ninety five it looks like he may have
won ninety four still not over
and now it's finally over and ten wins
the first bowling game he wins games and
he wins an end game and five minutes off
the match clock and you gotta believe
that there is a chance for ding oh there
is absolutely win this entire match
if ding wins this is possible he's up by
two again with eighteen minutes
remaining
we injury for hikaru this is what he
does he creates counter play against his
opponent's king there you go and then
time pressure knight age five and he's
gonna start surrounding white's king all
of a sudden
yeah ding is pushing his pawn all right
can it get to a7 it can't get there fast
enough
hikaru cooking up his own counter played
bishop h6 uh-oh
it's gonna be problems for white ding
might have to go king f2 yeah and then
queen h4 will come
hikaru is completely in control here
does he dare go to d3 he
yeah he's got the knight covering it
queen f4 was the mistake you carry
underestimating that now ding has his
pawn on a7 yeah but can he get back to
e3
now now he wants rook b8 but can he
dodge king f2 and rook b8 is coming he's
going to make a second queen
he can make a queen right now and win
the game immediately you should just
make a queen here
takes on f8 queen b4
oh my goodness and ding is back up by
two
if ding holds this one you might win the
match two minutes remaining this is
likely to be the last game oh my
goodness the car with the white pieces
though he's played very well in the
bullet with white he needs to win just
to force
over knockout
and for ding if ding feels that he's
losing bleeding out the clock and
forcing a tiebreaker might be the way to
go
yeah oh my goodness can hikara win on
demand to tie the match
oh my goodness how do you use the 50
seconds in a situation like this well
everybody is holding their breath tara's
got to be very careful not to repeat it
three times by accident yeah yeah
don't play knight h4 here i think that
last end game the night end game was
drawn by repetition by accident like h1
yeah it definitely was and hikara taking
no chances you're doubling now on the h
file that bishop on h6 is so vulnerable
how is his thing going to hold
everything together
he's got no time this is he's got he's
got five seconds he's gonna play
instantly in exchange here whoa bishop
see what it was a mouse now slip he was
going to d2 oh he was going to d2 but it
was still bad rook h7 check would have
been terrible yeah oh my goodness icaru
saves the match with a win in the last
game and we're going to overtime we're
going to the tiebreaker it'll be four
one plus one games
oh my goodness and ding is sitting back
and he can't believe it
and ikaru wins the one of the clutches
games of his online career but now he's
got to follow it up
with a dominating performance in the
tiebreaker david wow oh my gosh it's the
match that everybody wanted that is
fantastic what he's just done
okay 15 seconds for ding to hold on to
this one which is not like looking good
at all
yeah but
i mean if you can get the rook
straighted i think you'll be okay
icaru can't really get the bishop in any
way to attack the the d-pawn right
which is i guess i'm thinking queen a2
here to trade queens go to the rook
ending play e5 and bring the king to c4
yeah that's what he's doing and he's
definitely gonna play e5 i love that
idea
yeah and he's not letting this
opportunity slip he's gonna try
everything he can ding trying to get his
own king
closer to the to the queen side and here
comes cicara's king f5 g4
no the ding is not saving this game
there's no way
that there's nobody threatened by h4
and then the king's gonna come to g4
h4 king h5 king g4
and then h3 has a pawn sack and the king
goes to f3 or something yep exactly
exactly
you even have time to to take on history
car choosing to treat the bishops
okay declining that
h3 would have been very strong
in that position
interesting we're just burning some more
time here
bishop g3
bishop takes c3 is very strong i think
yeah
and dang is going to lose
oh that was just a squoosh man just a
squish that's how you use an open file
folks for anybody in an opening
bishop g7 knight g7 queen h6 and knight
g5 i say just do it no ding he's done
that way too many times this match dude
he's waiting for 63 bishop h7 bishop c3
bishop h7 oh my goodness so much tactics
is being missed here i'm shocked yeah
bishop takes g7 he has to see bishop g7
queen h6 and knight g5 that is and he
does and kudos to ding he saw it when he
played bishop d2 he's saying i'm
repeating that position
oh he did take on g7 oh my god the board
was messed up and he found the whole
lion it's mate queen h7
yeah where's the mate or rook takes c6
maybe knight takes c6
rook v8 what a move amazing queen h7
queen 8 shade queen takes v8 amazing
it's like what hakaro did with rook a1
wins we're down to the wire again this
is the last game of the tie break over
time game four of four the match is tied
icaro is in huge huge trouble in this
game he's gonna retreat the knight to to
not bring the queen
but where would he go because ding
threatens knight
queen f2 oh he invites the knight to h4
as well it should be three what a move
by hikaru what a counter getting his
rook out of the gate out of the gates oh
he's still in bad shape though
he takes me to he blunders the pun well
he had to because i mean the b2 was
already dead
but he didn't take it yeah thing going
for me but i full disregard for the
queen side by the players here when he
takes b2 was winning pretty much on the
spot yeah we won by hikaru tucking his
queen in ding
rook to the second still very bad for
white rook takes b2 it's time to grab
that pawn threatening
bishop not interested he wants me yeah
nothing but mate wait why didn't you
show bishop f4 i don't know queen g1
queen back to g1
rook f3 maybe
oh
everybody's dream come true more games
no ding wants checkmate
i don't know if he does he's got 12
seconds he's got no time i don't i don't
see the win i don't know if i agree
we're going or we're getting we keep
going we're going to armageddon
unbelievable hikaru survives
that was amazing
with bishop e3
what a setup and actually at the end i
like ding's decision because the apon
was hurtling down the board black could
lose that really easily too
so i wouldn't trust the eval bar there i
actually really like the fact that the
armageddon that the match isn't decided
by a bullet game because matches like
these deserve to be decided by a sort of
serious longer game i'm very curious to
see what side hikaru has chosen i would
imagine that he's chosen black given
that to him a time deficit isn't such a
big deal but the onus of winning the
game is is a huge one i always feel like
black
is on the better side of at armageddon
and there we go but they got to reset
the times there we go hicario has four
minutes the thing has five
certainly in this match black has has
done very well so
oh my god buckle your seat belts now
we're gonna have a much slower opening
here let's not expect anybody to blitz
out any moves there's no increment
though there is no increment which means
flagging is very much on the table david
bishop's back to c5 and we're going to
see a trade of brooks which generally
speaking is fine for black here
yeah i know
i think generally speaking it's an
improvement for black to get rid of
white's only rook
so but the a pawn that's that's like a
big target for white right now that
bishop is quite a good year yeah knight
okay so ding going a5 yeah he is trying
to go for that pawn i think he wants to
play queen a6 yeah but hikaru has some
way does hikara have some way to
neutralize this initiative because the
eva are showing equality i don't see it
off the top of my head a night before
oh queen takes a seven takes takes a
knight c6 maybe
okay and then maybe
with rook a8
wow back to d5 maybe we'll see a6 just
fixing the pawn on a7
i would highly consider that by ding and
he plays it
it's too intense
it's hard to play for he is still down a
minute on the clock and now he's got a
minute and a half with no increment
ding needs to be aware of that because
this might come down to flagging
if they can keep a time advantage
that's for sure and the tension is there
for this game to like not have too many
more trades yeah even hikaru has to take
but but but dengue is not making any
progress in the meantime ikaro has
centralized his pieces he's kind of
pressuring a6 and thinks time advantage
beginning to dwindle right this is i
would give hikaru the
the benefit of the doubt here i think
he's holding this rook c8 chasing the
queen around now he's not worse anymore
and now another queen trade offered
maybe dick just
takes it i don't know
it should pay seven knight before now he
can finally take on a7
yeah he couldn't because of knight f4
check this is what he was
maneuvering for queenie foreck but then
dink defends the bishop
yeah andy carlo has to take more time
here queen g6 is also an interesting
move big choice here he's still got a
minutes not it's not
he's not out of resources here yet
knight b5 knight c7
takes takes knight b5 regard has just
moved knight c7 and if knight c6 knight
bef
knight c7 anymore c7 anyway yeah and
dang has to flag him here one minute on
the clock black is
obviously not worse anymore although how
do you knight b5 knight before this move
was tricky this was really tricky he
finds it maybe four what a movie
yes yes yes
97 and b6 and white's going to be a pawn
up in that end game will ding see it
will ding c97 and b6 that is his only
chance to keep the sound game going
that's the time but he misses it
he misses it and he collapses rick b7
king f7 king e6
yeah oh my goodness that but
rook a5
okay
the black is not gonna give up the e4
pawn and in that case white's not
winning that game
ding overlooked it
ding missing that tactical shot which
would have given him the chances and now
he doesn't see a movie carl might pull
this one out i don't i don't see a way
to not lose the b pawn for nothing you
can and the evil bar is bearing that um
you can go 97 ica but that knight's not
remaining on see this is essentially the
match right here that would just trap
your own knight um it'll eventually be
lost there after the king
i mean ding has to give up the pawn and
then move the knight around he car is
not losing this game he's got more time
on the clock
yeah
and ding sitting back basically
admitting defeat
and what a painful match for dingley ran
who came so close so many times and what
an incredible effort but at the end of
the day
this honestly proves ikaro's dominance
maybe more than any other crushing
matches
yeah
if he can pull one a match like this out
where it seems like nothing's going his
way
that just tells you so much about his
ability and it's that's it the match is
over ding resigns yeah and hikaru
nakamura wins the armageddon against
dingley run to make it to the sec finals
king clutch the king of blitz
coming through yet again david what an
unbelievable match we just saw
[Music]
you